a couple generations ago
we know if you don't have it people are
being left behind in multiple ways
but we haven't finished the job
especially as it comes to rural america
and rural wisconsin
we know that lead lateral pipes in
homes and schools bring lead-laden water
to too many children and families but we
haven't finished the job
of removing those lead laterals
we also know that if we reach these
aspirations
of building back better that it is
literally across the united states
going to create millions of
good paying union jobs
and strengthen the ranks of organized
labor
we have a tremendous opportunity
that opportunity is presented as part of
the
bipartisan plan that ron kind was just
talking about
but also there'll be extra work to do
beyond that and that means
making sure that our workers have
what it was required to get the job done
that means a compliment to the
bipartisan bill
that involves making sure that
kids have saved child care while mom and
dad work
so this
is a moment of extraordinary opportunity
and we can't let that opportunity pass
i am thrilled to introduce to you
someone who needs no introduction but i
remember well campaigning with him
a few years back on an old school bus
where he got a chance to experience the
roads
that he pledged to repair on a school
bus
where he was focusing on education
we have a real partner a partnership
between
federal government state government
local government
please give a warm welcome
to governor tony evers
[Music]
good afternoon it is a pleasure and an
honor to be here in beautiful lacrosse
the sun is out
it is not out in madison so the sun is
out here and
it's out because we're here to welcome
president biden back to the great
state of wisconsin the president
and his administration have made
wisconsin a regular stop because they
know
how important a dairy state is the
health and wealth of
our nation and in recovering from this
pandemic to move forward
together whether it's getting vaccine
shots in
arms or the support of the american
rescue plan act
we appreciate president biden's
continued commitment
to ensuring our state and country
recover together
and move beyond the coronavirus pandemic
with the help of everybody from our
federal partners to our state agencies
to our local
and county and and also tribal health
departments wisconsin is bouncing back
and better we continue to be a national
leader in
getting available shots and arms and our
unemployment rate
has nearly returned to pre-pandemic
levels
but in order for us to in order for our
recovery to be successful
and president biden knows this as well
we have to do what i like to call
connecting the dots which is just to say
we have to see how each
issue in our state and country affects
all of them whether supporting working
families with affordable
accessible child care and health care
investing in job training
and transit to help folks get to work
ensuring clean air land and drinking
water for the health and wellness of our
communities
are bolstering our agricultural and
rural communities with broadband access
we've got to connect the dots to sure
that every kid
in every wisconsinite has a chance to
succeed
when i ran for office i said we're going
to fix the darn roads
and we've got to work doing just that
that's why i'm especially glad to see
the president's commitment to investing
in our infrastructure
from expanding broadband to replacing
lead service lines to
transitioning to electric transit much
like what
we will have in la crosse these
investments are exactly what we need to
keep bouncing back
from this pandemic and content and
continuing our economic recovery
and this plan is proof that we don't
have to choose between
mitigating climate change and protecting
our environment
and good paying jobs and economic
development these goals
are mutually ex these are not mutually
exclusive goals
we can and we should do both wisconsin
is ready for bold and urgent solutions
to address the challenges we're facing
in the 21st century
and we're excited to get to work and the
efforts of president biden to support
our state
so with that it's my pleasure to welcome
president biden to wisconsin thank you
[Music]
gravity is so crazy
[Music]
[Music]
captain can you hear me
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
when you get
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can leave
[Music]
i
[Music]
cuz
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the funky
[Music]
we call that classy press
[Music]
[Music]
hi guys
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the same
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like a preacher
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
time
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
lacrosse mtu bus driver
and proud atu 519 member laurie
[Music]
nederlow
[Music]
thank you everybody for coming my name
is laurie netterlow
i am a bus driver for the city of la
crosse i am a proud member
of the atu local 519. public
transportation has been a
very important part of my life since i
was a child
it's how i got to school and work it's
always been a vital service for myself
and our entire community it is necessary
for our success
i'm honored to have the opportunity to
work with 47
incredible employees at the atu local
519
who help people that may not have their
own means of transportation
to access the necessities of life
many of our employees are the first and
the last person
our passengers may see on any given day
that simple interaction can play a major
role on how
someone's day may turn out it's truly
amazing what bus
operators undertake on a daily basis
working long hours
and ensure safe and reliable service to
our community
in order to have successful
transportation service we need better
roads
better bridges and clean renewable
energy to properly serve our community
i am a proud i am proud to say that
lacrosse has led the way
on this front with the introduction of
hybrid buses
and future electric buses in our fleet
every town has a role in the fight for
clean energy
no matter how big or small we are we are
doing our part to make this happen
the american jobs plan will have a huge
impact across the country
including right here in the cross it
means less potholes
better roads better bridges and cleaner
energy
these things are vital to the success of
our city
our state and our country president
biden's vision
reveals the potential of our workforce
and unlock the american dreams
this opens doors and creates
opportunities for everyone to succeed
and now it is my pleasure to introduce
the president united states
joe
[Applause]
take biden of them
[Music]
good afternoon
thank you laurex please please please
sit down
i once said that the big crowd was in
the evening
i said please sit down and there were no
seats that are on the football field
and the press pointed out biden's losing
it
well i can see you all had seats
lori thank you very much i told laurie
when she was showing me
the bus she's driving now
back when i was in law school i drove a
school bus during the summers to pick up
spend the money and from one bus driver
to another lorry
i want to thank for all you do to make
this city run
to help folks get where they need to go
and you do it in a way that
sometimes is not always easy i'm glad to
be here
with great wisconsin leaders gov i guess
i landed at the airport just a few
minutes before you did thank you for
making the effort
to be here my good friend tammy baldwin
senator baldwin is here
congressman ron kind is a and mom
thank you for raising a good kid
[Applause]
mayor reynolds i was telling the mayor
he just won re-election he won election
and i said you know i always wonder
about everybody who runs for mayor
because they it's the hardest job in
american politics
they know where you live you can't go to
the grocery store
why is that pothole still there i get it
you don't even control that
and that way mr mayor thank you for your
service thank you for willing to serve
i'm here in wisconsin to celebrate a
step forward for my country
our country talk a little bit about what
it's going to mean for working families
here in wisconsin
and across the nation when i was sworn
in
five months ago i pledged to put my
whole
soul into bringing america together i
said i was running for three reasons the
last one of which i said is
unite america i admit it's difficult
and i think some of my friends in the
press thought it was impossible
i still don't think it is but because i
believe that there's nothing we cannot
do
if we bring to come together as a nation
democrats and republicans
and we're really divided in a whole
range of things
if you look back across our history from
the trans continental railroad to the
creation of the internet
you can see the truth in that idea about
coming together
because america america has always been
propelled
into the future by landmark national
investments
investments that only the government has
the capacity to make
only the government working together
could make today
happens the mark is coincidental but
today
is the 60th anniversary of one of those
significant investments to change the
nation
65 years ago today president dwight
eisenhower
signed a bill that created the
interstate highway system
65 years ago today that was the
last infrastructure investment of the
size and scope
of what agreement i'm about to talk
about today
it's time for us to write a new chapter
in that story
after months of of a careful negotiation
of listening compromising together and
in good faith moving together
with ups and downs and some blips a
bipartisan group of senators
got together and they forged an
agreement
to move forward on the key priorities of
my american jobs plan
and one of them sitting in front of me
as a result
this is a generational investment a
generational investment to modernize our
infrastructure
creating millions of good paying jobs
that's not coming from me that's coming
from wall street millions of good paying
jobs
and positioned america to compete
with the rest of the world the 21st
century because china is
way out working us in terms of
infrastructure
it's going to make the world of
difference for families here in
wisconsin
here's what it's going to do this deal
will put american workers to work in
good paying jobs not minimum wage jobs
not 15
an hour job prevailing wage jobs good
paying
jobs repairing our roads and our bridges
we all know why that matters one in five
miles of highway
and roads in america are in poor
condition
one in five miles some states it's worse
where the weather is tougher
50 years 50 of our bridges
are over 50 years old more than 1 000
bridges here in wisconsin
are rated as structurally deficient by
engineers
1 000 just in wisconsin
and i'm not that doesn't make wisconsin
better or worse it's all across the
nation
it's this way the bridge is the 10 most
travel bridges in america need repair
and some need to be completely rebuilt
more than 600 more than 600 here in the
state of wisconsin
bridges have weight limits to prevent
trucks from crossing
that means long detours for farmers
heading to market
it's more than just an inconvenience
about safety as well
in november 2019 a school bus in arcadia
wisconsin
tipped over going around a curve went to
a dish with 20 students on board it
wasn't because of snow or ice
it was just an old country road with
rough conditions
thank god nobody was seriously injured
at the time
but this is a drain on our economy as
well
american typical american and very
slightly from state to state
but the typical american pays a hidden
tax more than 1 000
a year in wasted time
wasted time and fuel due to traffic
congestion
now and the more rural the areas the
less the congestion
but it creates other difficulties you
all know that feeling
losing time sitting in traffic or being
rerouted because the bridge
isn't wide enough the road is poorly
maintained
this deal is going to put americans back
to fixing all of that
and good paying jobs this deal will also
put americans to work replacing
100 of our nation's lead water pipes
you know there's four hundred thousand
well i won't get into the numbers i
get a little carried away but it's
really dangerous every single american
child
at home or in school will soon be able
to turn on that faucet and their moms
and dads know that
water they're drinking is clean and safe
to give you an example of why that
matters just look at the city of
milwaukee
milwaukee has more than 160
000 water service lines
more than 70 000 of them nearly half
have lead service lines and by the way
i'm not
it's not picking on wisconsin every
state's like this but just to know
what you're going to be doing for the
state of wisconsin here
you know we know the exposure to lead
and drinking water can trigger a number
of serious problems
even low levels of love can cause
behavioral learning problems in children
impairing their growth
they're up to 10 million homes with lead
pipe service lines and pipes
children in up to 400
000 schools 400 000 schools and child
care facilities
are at risk of exposure to lead this
deal contains the largest investment
in clean drinking water and wastewater
infrastructure in american history
this dose also provides something you're
very familiar with in the island
provides funding to get dangerous
chemicals out of our water systems
known as pfas or forever chemicals
this is a problem all across the country
and i know that you're feeling it right
here
right here here in la crosse county just
this spring
the state had to provide free bottled
water to thousands of people on french
island because they were worried about
those chemicals
in the groundwater which were linked to
cancer and other illnesses
we'll pay for that we'll get that done
we're also going to surge federal
resources to help address the forever
chemicals not just here
but all across america unfortunately
wisconsin is not unique in this problem
this deal will also put america's work
building transmission lines
the largest investment in clean energy
transmission
in american history power outages cost
the
u.s economy up this now this is you know
we know this but until you
add it up it doesn't seem to be that big
a deal it cost
the economy congressman 70
billion dollars annually hear me
nationally
70 billion annually and as climate
change induces extreme weather events
more and more
frequently we need to make investments
to build a more resilient
grid to carry this electricity majority
of the nation's grid is aging
some components are over a century old
and 70 percent the transmission and
distribution lines
are well into the second half of their
lifespans
you saw what happened in texas this
winter
the entire system in the state collapsed
the entire system that's all we have to
act
this deal will modernize the power grid
be more energy efficient
and resilient and resistant to extreme
weather
resilient against bad actors who try to
hack
and attack the grid because i spent a
lot of time in europe trying to work on
that
and it's going to strengthen and
revitalize our natural infrastructure
like our coastlines and levees while
preparing our physical infrastructure
for wildfires floods
and other extreme weather anybody ever
believe you
turn on the news and say it was 116
degrees in portland
oregon 116
but don't worry there is no global
warming
it doesn't exist as a figment of our
imagination
seriously when a severe storm rolls in
like you had in some parts of the state
just recently
the power is going to be less likely to
go out town water systems will be able
to withstand what happens
if we make these investments
and all as all of you know america is
one of the highest road fatality rates
of anywhere in the industrial world we
said it again
the highest road fatality rates of any
industrial nation in the world
i lost a wife and daughter and almost
lost two sons
look our fatality rate is double the
rate in canada
on a per capita basis i bet every one of
you here
can tell me what the most dangerous
intersections in your town are
i'll lay eight to five no matter what
the town is maybe you don't have many
but everybody knows what intersections
are the most dangerous
when you're teaching your kid to drive
what do you do you tell them no don't go
down that road
when you come home i'm being deadly
earnest when you come home come home the
other way
well guess what we got an agreement to
invest
11 billion dollars to help cities and
locales reduce crashes and fatalities in
their communities
especially for cyclists and pedestrians
which are increasing and significant
this deal is going to more than double
the funding
directed to state and local programs
that improve the safety of people and
vehicles including
highway safety truck safety pipeline and
hazard material
safety i wanted to get into this now but
you know
we have we have thousands of miles of
pipeline
the vast majority of those pipes are 60
years or older
some of them more than 80 years old a
lot of them are leaking
this is the united states of america for
god's sake
what are we not doing
this still also helped high-speed
internet and make sure it's available to
every american home including 35
of rural families who currently go
without it
as of last spring more than 82 000
children here in wisconsin which prides
itself on its education
didn't have reliable internet access at
home
think about that year and year of remote
schooling
when so many of our needs and our
connections were forced to move online
tens of thousands wisconsin kids got
left behind
did you ever think here in america the
kids would have to sit in the fast food
parking lot
just to do their school work and
homework because they can connect online
not a joke ask any mom
who has kids in school or dad who's
taken care of
no child should have to do that and no
farmer here in wisconsin should lose
business because they don't have
reliable connection internet no one to
buy no one to sell and know what's going
on
you know back in 1936 the federal
government
brought electricity to nearly every home
and farm in america and spread the
opportunity
out for cities in every part of the
country
to change the lives and fortunes of
thousands and thousands of homeowners
thousands of home towns and millions of
american families
and has set the stage for a massive
sustained economic boom that would
follow world war
ii high-speed internet is the equivalent
of that today
it's a similar it's an equivalent of
that it isn't a luxury
it's now a necessity like water and
electricity
and this deal would provide for it for
everyone while bringing down the cost of
internet service
across the board this deal has also put
americans to work through a first ever
national effort to install electric
vehicle charging stations
500 000 charging stations nationwide
along our highways
and in rural and disadvantaged
communities as well
think about what that can mean to the
american auto worker and the future of
electric
vehicles china is going full
bore we're providing more electric
vehicles than any nation in the world
you know it used to be when i first got
the united states
senate actually a couple actually in the
60s when i was getting out late
60s getting out of law school what
happened
we invested more in r d and investment
in manufacturing than any nation in the
world
now we're number eight in the world
china used to be number nine
now they're number two in the world
and when you build a charging station it
spurs even more investment and more
infrastructure around it
the local convenience store the local
hamburgers place
you know think about nobody's old enough
but my dad used to tell me because he
worked
back in the days for the american oil
company they came along
with the auto of the combustion engine
he needed to be able to put gas in the
engine
i mean the car the tank
well guess what you had to build gas
stations
one of my dad's jobs my grandpa biden's
job is to go from city to city
convincing them was okay to bury these
great big tanks
with gasoline and entire communities
grew up around it
well this is exactly what we have to do
with regard to electric vehicles
this deal is also going to help our
cities our towns our school district
deploy electric buses 35
000 electric school buses are accounted
for
there are about 475 000 school buses in
this country
95 of them like the ones you had here
is he okay honey sure
he took a little bit of a tumble
95 of them run on diesel
so every day more than 25 million
kids and thousands of bus drivers
breathe polluted air
on the way to and from school diesel air
pollution is linked to asthma
and other health problems it hurts
communities it causes students to get
sick
and miss time in school we owe it to our
kids to clean up the school buses and
this deal will help do just that
i know that the city of lacrosse is
getting two electric transit
buses this fall i think i saw them both
i was down in the carolinas
looking at the bus company where you're
going to buy them charging stations to
power you
this bipartisan deal by the way you had
half republicans and half democrats come
along and present this deal negotiators
do it
it's going to help advance that effort
this still
also also modernizes our outdated
airports
ports and waterways that means fewer
delays
have drained away so much money from
families and from businesses
there's no good reason why that zero
zero of the top 25 airports in the world
are
american zero not
one in the united states of america
this did will put americans to work
through long overdue
national environmental cleanups it means
good
paying jobs capping hundreds of
thousands of abandoned oil and gas wells
that need to be cleaned up and capped
methane leaks protecting the health of
our communities
making the same money it took to dig
that well
there's thousands of them not to mention
this deal represents the largest
investment in american passenger rail
and then freight rail since the creation
of amtrak
now i know i'm mr amtrak i've traveled
over 2 million miles in that truck i
commute
every day i get it i know you think i'm
nuts but after my wife and daughter were
killed i decided to commute back and
forth to delaware
the 257 mile round trip
i'll tell you a real quick story i
shouldn't bore you with it but
you know the secret service the best in
the world
doesn't like you taking amtrak these are
stops too many times on the train
they want me flying home and small jets
are available as vice president
and but that costs a lot of money so i
would i would go home on fridays
because my mom was passing away i'd go
home on amtrak
and they've published they keep
fastidious
record of the mile as you travel in the
america
in a air force aircraft as president
vice president
before the end of my term headline came
out in all the papers biden
travels i think it was 1.3 or 1.7
million miles
on the air force plans and so i'm
getting on the
train on that friday and these guys all
became my family all the conductors
and a guy named angelo negri came up he
goes joey baby
grabbed my cheek like that and i thought
they're going to shoot him i really did
no no no no no he's a friend he's like
what the hell
he said big deal joey a million whatever
it was 300 000 miles
you know how many miles you travel on
amtrak joey
and i said no ange i know what he said
at turner we calculated
we estimated 127
days a year 250 miles back and forth
three
36 years then as vice president joey
you travel more on amtrak
well i uh when they
named a station after my city someone
complained that biden was using his
influence
i said hell they should name the whole
northeast carter after me
more than anybody else but all can
decide studies show
if you can get to your destination in
the same amount of time or less on rail
than you can by car
people will take rail and gov you know
this but
anybody imagine if you could get from
chicago
from lacrosse to chicago in two hours
instead of four and a half that's what
this would allow us to build a capacity
to do
and besides would not only make your
travel easier
not i don't know why i'd go to chicago
but you know all kidding aside
it would reduce the largest source of
pollution
in america vehicle travel
we're not just tinkering around the
agency we're going to invest
66 billion dollars in rail to eliminate
backlogs
bring world-class rail service to areas
outside the northeast
here in wisconsin we'll add new stops in
green bay madison and eau claire
this deal also makes the largest
investment of public transit in american
history
a whole lot of people here in wisconsin
depend on public transportation
like the bus system here in la crosse to
get to work to school to get around
because of this deal will be easier
quicker cleaner more frequent and more a
bit more reliable
more transit options mean more people
can access good
access good jobs as well one study found
that it leads to higher wages for
workers because businesses can attract
more customers
with the rail this bipartisan
breakthrough is a great deal for the
american people
not just for folks in cities not just
for red states or blue states but for
everybody
this job this jobs
the jobs that are going to be created
here
largely will be those for blue collar
workers
the majority of whom will not have to
have a college degree to have those jobs
a lot of those folks are being left
behind now the guys who grew up with
this grammy claim on i mean left behind
this is the answer for good paying jobs
jobs in this job jobs not just in our
biggest cities
along our coasts but in small towns
across the country
so families can build wealth and
opportunity in rural hometowns and don't
have to leave when they're grown up
i've said it all along this is a
blue-collar blueprint
to rebuild america and long before
families in wisconsin are going to see
the benefits
firsthand look i'm always quoting my dad
because he was smart and i loved him my
dad used to say joey your job's about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community i
mean he really would say this
when he lost everything in scranton and
we had to move down to claim on delaware
a little steel town
and he said and the deal is going to
deliver a breathing room
all he said was all you want is a
middle-class person
is just have a little bit of breathing
not just a little bit of breathing
that's why we got to build this economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
not trickle down creating good-paying
jobs with dignity
and jobs that cannot be outsourced
and critically we're going to get it all
done without raising taxes on a single
american earning less than
400 000 now all of you making over four
hundred thousand dollars i love you
but i don't mind a little bit if your
taxes go up
but all kidding aside i made a
commitment
nobody i would not support anything that
raised a penny in tax and someone make
under 400
and that means in this bill there is no
gas tax
working families have already paid
enough instead we're going to pay for
these investments in part by giving the
internal revenue service the resources
it needs to collect taxes on the
wealthiest americans
who owe and are currently not paying
under the existing tax rules and by the
way it's not done by this and
done by conservative economists and
liberal economists
it cracks down on tax chiefs not just
hard working middle class americans
and there's a lot of important
investments in this deal that are long
overdue
economists of all stripes agree that
it's going to create good jobs
and dramatically strengthen our economy
in the long run
it makes it easy for businesses to
seemingly transport their goods
makes it easier workers more easily
access job opportunities
but the reason this agreement matters so
much is about what it represents
this deal isn't just the sum of its
parts it's a signal
to ourselves and to the world that
american democracy can come through and
deliver for all our people
we can't be united i just met with the
g7
i just met with all of nato i just met
with putin the autocrats think that
democracy can't keep up with autocrats
not a joke but it's living proof we can
still come together in this country and
accomplish something big
and transformational i know that neither
democrats nor republicans get everything
they want
it's not all that i propose but that's
what our economy is all about
that's what it means to compromise and
reach consensus and that's what every
in the heart of every democracy and we
can't give up
on what we keep finding ways to come
together
because every time we negotiate in good
faith and come together and get
something big done
we break a little more of the ice that
too often keeps us frozen in place and
prevents us from solving
real problems people are facing let me
be clear there's much more to do
and i'm going to continue to fight for
more i'm going to keep working
with congress to pass even more of my
economic agenda
so we can keep building an economy from
the bottom up in the middle out
as we bring home key parts of my
american jobs plan
i'm going to make the case and i told
this to the negotiators
i'm going to i'm going to continue to
make the case their critical investments
are still needed including those in my
family plan
american family plan maybe the most
important among them is extending
the child tax credit which will
significantly benefit middle class and
working folks let me explain what that
is
pretty soon taxpayers in america
are going to get a significant check
back from the irs
for example if you are
if you have to pay taxes and you have a
good income
you get to deduct 2 000 per dependent
per child and that comes off the bottom
line your taxes and you probably still
owe more after
that's cut off but for families
for families who in fact don't have that
big a tax bill
they don't get anything from this so we
changed the law this year
and it's cutting child poverty by 40
percent and here in wisconsin
by july 15th we're going to start people
they're going to be picking them and
calling you and say thanks god
they're going to get checks from the irs
here's what they did
for every child you have under the age
of 6 you're going to get 3
600. and for every child
under the age of between over the age of
12
you're gonna get three thousand dollars
so you'll actually get a cash payment
instead of just a credit against your
taxes because you don't pay that many
taxes if you're
if you're making and making the minimum
wage or you're making
20 30 40 000 a year
and people say well that's a giveaway
hey guys
i think it's time to give ordinary
people a tax break
the wealthy are doing fine i mean it
i mean it why is this
not a tax break for working folks
when the stuff we give to the super
wealthy are called tax breaks
look major action on clean energy
housing caregiving
on child and paid leave universal pre-k
free community college
the human infrastructure is intertwined
with our physical infrastructure it's
going to help us
create more good jobs ease the burden of
working families and strengthen our
economy in the long run
and i'm going out and i'm going to be
out there making the case
for the american people until this job
is done
until we bring this bipartisan deal home
until our human infrastructure also
needs are met
until we have a fair tax system to pay
for all of them so by the way
what i'm talking about in the family
plan let me tell you i'm gonna pay for
it
and the american people in the polling
data overwhelm we support it
if we just raise the corporate tax to 28
it used to be 35 was supposed to come
down to 20 it's now
21. you raise it to 28 how much money
that raises
1.4 trillion
if you have a minimum global tax which
we agreed to in europe
that means so corporations can't avoid
paying the taxes at home
that would generate in america 385
billion dollars
if you end deductions from foreign
corporations who ship their profits out
of the united states
that raises 260 billion dollars in these
tax havens
you know there are 30 corporations in
america the fortune 500
making billion i come from the corporate
capital of the world
delaware not a joke more corporations
are incorporated in delaware than all
the rest of america
combined okay
well guess what 15 of the fortune
500 companies last year paid
i mean 30 excuse me paid zero taxes
they made billions of dollars paid not a
penny in tax
not a single cent i'm not trying to
punish anybody
i'm just saying let's be fair if you
just set up a minimum tax
you had to pay at least 15 of your
earnings
as a corporation that alone
would raise 230
billion dollars the point is
i have never had a reputation of being
someone who's out there
trying to just out tax me here's the
deal folks
i think it's about time to be fairness
in testing
i don't want you paying more than your
share with the tax cut that was passed
under trump
for two trillion dollars not a penny of
which was paid for
where'd it go over 80 percent of it went
to the top one quarter of one percent
i think you should be able to be a
billionaire i think you should be able
to be a millionaire
but for god's sake at least pay
pay your fair share pay your fair share
folks a lot of worker ahead to finish
the job
of just outline there'll be more
disagreements to resolve
more compromises to forge along the way
but today
the american people can be proud that
democrats and republicans
families here in wisconsin to be proud
congress can be proud because this
country
came together forged a bipartisan deal
with a lot has to do with your state
your senator
that delivers for everybody we've shown
the world
and just as importantly we've shown
ourselves that american democracy
can come through there's nothing nothing
nothing beyond our capacity we come
together as one nation
so thank you wisconsin thank you all for
who you are and what you do may god
bless you all and make god protect our
troops
thank you
we take care of them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
we take
[Music]
[Music]
we take
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hold you keep holding to your face
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to give you an apology
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
either
come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes
[Music]
makes no difference
[Music]
everyday
[Music]
we got to live together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
everyday
[Music]
too
he's
[Music]
[Music]
the world he left behind
not so long ago
he's leaving leaving that big knife
[Music]
sometimes
[Applause]
[Music]
i'd rather live in his word
than live without him
the dreams don't always come true
[Music]
to the line
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
waiting
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
thank
all
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
does that work